the big there there are two big stories
today one
popped yesterday mid to late morning
and then the other one came out of the
blue the first one we expected we're
gonna get to that and we're gonna put a
pin in that one the second one came out
of the blue
seven years after michael sam
announced that he's gay before the
2014 draft ultimately was a
seventh-round pick of the rams
ultimately cut by the rams signed by the
cowboys on the practice squad never made
it to an active roster
thought about going to canada i think
did go to the cfl for a little bit yeah
that wasn't for him right and you know
what
i i whatever the case may be
and in the final analysis the thinking
was he just wasn't good enough even
though he was the
i think sec defensive player of the year
in 2013. missouri yep
we now have an active player who's been
in the league for multiple years
and who is clearly good enough to stay
on the raiders roster carl nasib
came out yesterday here's the video that
he posted
on social media what's up people i'm
carl nasa
i'm at my house here in westchester
pennsylvania just want to take a quick
moment to say that i'm gay
i've been meaning to do this for a while
now but i finally feel comfortable
enough to get it off my chest
i really have the best life i got the
best family friends and job a guy could
ask for
i'm a pretty private person so i hope
you guys know that i'm really not doing
this for attention
i just think that representation and
visibility are so important
um i actually hope that like one day
videos like this and the whole coming
out process are
just not necessary but until then you
know i'm going to do my best and do my
part to cultivate a culture that's
accepting that's compassionate
and i'm going to start by donating 100
000 to the trevor project
they're an incredible organization
they're the number one suicide
prevention service for lgbtq youth in
america
and they're truly doing incredible
things and i'm very excited to be
a part of it to help in any way that i
can and i'm really pumped to see what
the future holds
that's all i have for you guys i hope
you have a great day work hard
and he mentioned the trevor project a
very worthwhile
endeavor for anyone to support we'll
make sure that the information is
available at pft for anybody who would
like to
help out it's thetrevorproject.org but
again i'll be posting something
later today with all the relevant
information for anyone who would like to
to help that out and
hey look it i've got mixed emotions
about this because of something that he
said
okay i wish we already were at the point
where it's no big deal because in the
rest of society for the most part
right it is no big deal i remember when
i was growing up and you would hear
stories about people who were gay
and were thinking about coming out to
their family and it was like
the worst thing you could do because you
just expected
that one or more of your immediate
family members we're going to reject you
we're not going to accept you we're
going to judge you
we're going to try to change you in some
way they were going to think it was
something
that was negative so it was this
horribly traumatic experience
that anyone who was thinking about
informing their family members of
dreaded yeah and that's changed over the
past 50 years
and it feels like it's been almost
exponential the last decade or so
i think once the nation got over its
hang up on gay marriage
right i think we got a lot closer to the
point where it's no big deal
i i long for the day that people can
just be who they are
and it's not a big deal if someone's gay
or trans or whatever
right you just are who you are exactly
we all accept each other for who we are
and we live our lives
and it does and i think part of it is
getting older when you have less life to
live
you realize all the crap that people
worry about
and like look at other people and say
you're different so you scare me i worry
and influence my kids or whatever
why worry about it let people live their
lives right and i hope we get to that
point it's and
it needed we needed one and it's good
that we got one
i just hope that we quickly get to the
point where
it's not a story and it's not an issue
yeah hopefully like this is like uh kind
of
mirror society like you're saying
because we've seen like the evolution of
it a little bit to your right to like
where
your era it was like whoa this is really
crazy i'm not
i'm afraid to come out and do that my
era
you know it was a little more advanced
maybe maybe
guys girls that were lesbian or gay came
out at the end of high school or college
right felt comfortable in that time
period
now we're in a time period where hey you
know my
my eighth grade daughter she's got
friends that are gay that's just the way
the life is but
it's not the way life is in the nfl
world and that's where
it's really brave on carl nassive and
awesome that he did this
because like we know this is the
last of the industries in the world that
has really
i don't know i don't want to say it's
accepting of the gay community and
things like that
but it's not necessarily like open arms
to the gay community like hey come into
our workplace this is an awesome place
for the gay community that's where the
nfl is a little different you know
everybody realizes that there might be
that person in the locker room or
in the nfl organization but no one ever
knew it was kind of kept quiet
carl nasa a lot of credit like really
courageous the fact that he's coming out
and doing
this because it's not going to be
accepted by everybody in an nfl locker
room
most a lot better than like you're
saying a long time ago
but still not going to be completely
fully understood or accepted quite yet
in the football industry
and i think when people witnessed what
happened with michael sam
yeah i i think that the reaction by
anyone
on a team coaching staff front office
who was even
contemplating the possibility of joining
michael sam
and being openly gay i think the
reaction was you know what this isn't
the place for it right
in the place for it right it creates
wait for it chris it creates a
distraction uh-oh
that needs to end that needs to end and
for a variety of reasons first of all
there should be no basis for it being a
distraction
when michael sam came out there was some
over-the-top
ridiculous reporting from espn about
shower habits
and i think an apology eventually was
issued in that regard and rightfully so
yeah and it's good it's fine i give him
credit i give him credit for realizing
that they shouldn't have done it but it
helps create the distraction
and i'm never one to say what questions
reporters should and shouldn't ask
because look you can ask whatever
questions you want if it's a bad
question you open yourself up to
ridicule but i think in this context
there's no reason to ask any questions
about it of carl nasib
of anyone in the locker room there's
really no reason to do it
you surely have something football
related because the mere asking of the
question
helps create the distraction that some
coaches
who just don't want an openly gay player
in their locker room will hide behind
and say i don't want the distraction
that that's the problem because
no you're right and this look shocker
shocker the nfl locker room is about 50
years behind the rest of society right
this is a huge step in forcing the nfl
locker room to catch up but i think we
all
everyone connected to the sport has an
obligation now
to accelerate that process and one way
to accelerate it is
don't make it a big deal if you're in
the media don't ask the questions
there's no there's no question to ask
there's nothing relevant to football
about carl nassif
at this point and hopefully that's
that's one factor in this
yeah once we digest it and everyone
issues their statement like they should
like
mark davis did like the commissioner did
like john gruden did we'll get to that
but once we get past that point let's
just all live our lives and not worry
about it
i i mean listen that that's awesome fine
and dandy i'm all for that i just i
don't know if that's like
gonna be reality i don't i mean this
this is
you know for what it's worth it's still
a a different type of workplace
yeah it's the machoist of the macho men
there is
a there is homophobic talk
and certainly you know homophobia in an
nfl locker room to a degree now it's a
lot less than now than it was
you know back in the day but some of
that goes on
so that's where i think like the media
is going to be you know
a little bit like whoa i'd like to know
more about the psychology about what's
going on here
in the workplace and where it's also
different from other workplaces is
you know you don't always get naked in
front of your other work mates and do
that type of stuff and just walk around
you know freely like that
naked in front of reporters i know i'm
just saying that's what makes no you
have to have no
shame to be in that locker room you're
right you make a good point though yeah
you make it
here's the point to the extent that
it's important for reporters to
to shine a light on any issues that may
arise
right then okay but let's wait and see
if issues arise yeah
because i i look at it this way the
players just follow the lead of
their coach and the coach does whatever
ownership allows the coach to do i
it's like anything else that once an
industry has its awakening and again
this happened for corporate america
years ago whether it's sexual harassment
whether it's how people who are
different
and protected by state federal and local
law are treated the things you can and
can't say to them
do you have hostility in the work
environment
that would support the person saying i
can't stay here
anymore right i can't do this
one of the most important episodes of
the office was the the
the episode where oscar comes out it
teaches us a lot about the way society
has been
and the way society should be but
i i think the obligation and the onus is
on the teams
and the coaches to make sure that to the
extent of that stuff so
happen in the year 2021 considering as i
said the exponential changes in society
we've seen really over the last 10 years
it it needs to stop it just needs to
stop and and
it's on ultimately the coaches and also
the team leaders
to make sure that that you know that
that just it just ends the attitude ends
the joking ends the terms that people
don't realize exactly right
that carry that connotation there are
common profane
terms that get used all the time that
carry a connotation
yeah and until people realize it they
don't stop doing it right
like evolve everybody like yes you have
to you we grew up in an era where
right i mean the word gay was thrown
around oh that's gay
or you know even the f word excuse me
i'm just saying it for an example but
you learned that it was bad and you
evolve and get better from that
you heard it you learned it offended
people so yeah i might have said it when
i was nine or ten
but then had like you know mom and dad
go christopher what the hell are you
doing don't say that
it's offensive and then you go okay wait
i'm hurting people's feelings let me
adjust from that
hopefully that can take place here in
the nfl locker room uh
that that and that's the that's the
point you've got you've got you've got
guys
who maybe didn't have yes the mom and
the dad around
to tell them what they should and
shouldn't do right the football coach
that tells them what they should and
shouldn't do it's their peers who tell
them
what they should and shouldn't say and
my point is this to the extent that
those attitudes still linger in men in
their mid
late 20s or even into their 30s the onus
is on the teams
to ferret that out to put an end to it
and and it's it's not enough for the nfl
to kind of pat itself on the back that
it's finally after all these years
gotten to the point
where a player felt sufficiently
comfortable to be openly gay i mean
frankly they're the last ones in the
pool yeah close to it
definitely right and i'd say it's not
like there's a lot of
professional sports male professional
sports where
where you know it's it's open season on
being openly gay there's always been
that negative connotation
whether it's basketball baseball hockey
or football but
there there's an obligation that comes
with
the acknowledgement that carl nasib has
has crossed a boundary that has never
before been publicly crossed
other than with michael sam who never
made it onto a 53-man roster so it's
different with carl nasim
and and i hope that the nfl and the
teams will go back and really study what
happened with michael sam
um and and learn from it again the
question it's always been he wasn't good
enough
yeah but i i still think that
when we get to the bottom of the roster
right
you you've got the distraction factor
that can maybe weigh down one player
100 caused him to no longer be part of
the team get a chance to develop maybe
if he would have had a chance to develop
he would have turned into a great player
we don't know
no there's only so many jobs so it
shouldn't be regarded as a distraction
it's up to the coaches to make sure it's
a distraction and chris one of the
things i've said
for years kind of the light went on for
me four or five years ago
why do coaches care about distractions
anyway everything you do on a football
field
happens in a crucible of distraction
you're trying to do this the other guy's
trying to do
that that's the biggest distraction you
can ever have
someone who is physically opposing your
effort to do what you're told to do
why do we care about distractions for a
football team so i just think that
for a variety of reasons people need to
kind of go back to square one
understand what happened seven years ago
and hopefully the nfl has evolved
or if it's not evolution hopefully it'll
be revolution but we get to a point
where
it's it's it's no big deal i mean i want
to fast forward to the point where
when a player decides to come out as gay
it doesn't even register
on anyone's radar screen that's what i
want to get to and i hope it happens
in my lifetime and hopefully as soon as
possible
no doubt that's where we need to get to
you're right and we're not there i mean
first off
the distraction thing just to answer
that well i mean
there is some merit to that coaches
don't want distractions because it's
hard enough to play in between that like
lines and all that you're talking about
with big people
and thinking about what you got to do
with all the distractions you're talking
about so they don't want anything like
wavering or or confusing them during the
week that gets them off that wavelength
or whatever so
that would be my answer to that that's
why it's at least a little you know i
i agree with it for a real distraction
the problem is you can make things that
shouldn't be distractions or you can
just apply that label to you you don't
like yes
right now if if i i can you know you
come up with all sorts of ridiculous
examples no you're right you could make
wouldn't like
yeah and and yeah it's it did i so it
becomes a crutch i think yes
it becomes a crutch for i just don't
want this guy around
yes and we we have to figure out how to
get past that no doubt now to me like
everything you're saying spot on we got
to get past that and i i mean like me
me mike i think right away i go to
football right away
and then now to me i want to go all
right so
i don't want this guy judged in the
locker room for the man he is or
anything like that
that's not fair you know this was
courageous
but here's where i do worry about like
the player
and now how he's evaluated a little bit
because of like what you're saying
oh it's kind of a distraction or
whatever but i don't want
now the fact that he's openly gay and
come out
to that be held against him you know
on the field oh he turns down a block
right or sorry there's a pulling guard
and he maybe doesn't take it on
aggressively enough you know our coaches
nfl personnel people like that gonna be
able to just
you know swipe down to the rug and just
go that was a man that
didn't take on a block or are they gonna
go well he's a little and like
that that's to me gonna be a big part of
this culture
i know i'm just telling you that's nfl
underscores
the point how far behind the rest of the
world the nfl
world is and you've got the perspective
you've been there in the last 20 years
you know what it's like you've heard the
comments you've
lived it so i i defer to your expertise
but
it's just disappointing i just know what
i'm judged on that to that degree
right that in this day and age a guy
would be judged on his aggressiveness
on the field based upon hey that's just
these are all the things that are said
in the nfl live you know just constantly
so
it is that it's that macho environment
and you know of course it's been there
for a long time
some people have not learned you know or
been taught or
you know the right way or or how to
treat people
but also there's an ingrained old-school
mentality of coaches that are
that are older than you in the nfl who
you know
just haven't opened up or evolved with
the world quite that way and
that's where i worry about a little bit
just as a guy talks on tv on the outside
looking in right now but i've been there
and
and i know how these guys think in a lot
in a lot of cases
but that's why it's the obligation of
the league
and owners and executives
to make sure the coaches know what is
and isn't acceptable maybe even monitor
i know yeah what are they saying what
are they doing
what's happening i just think the
obligation is greater than ever before
to make sure that
the locker room isn't a place where
people are made
to feel different where people are made
to feel
like they are distractions just based
upon who they
are and it's depressing to think
that that much work needs to be done but
i guess
it's good for us to shine a light on it
because
at a time when the nfl will be inclined
to do a little bit of a victory lap
that's gotten to the point where someone
is sufficiently comfortable to declare
that he's gay and that's fine and we go
forward
and everything should be okay we really
do have these other issues that we hope
the nfl
locker room has evolved beyond it's
going to be a test so again i
i i know how i think it
should be but now you have me concerned
that maybe it won't be and you know i
i look at i look i'm on ask i'm next
level sometimes mike and i even think
about his career and go well maybe
that's why he's already been on two
teams he's a pretty good player
but three yeah three brown's bucks and
race right
did somebody to me that uh you know i
wouldn't be shocked
if yeah that was part of the reason he
didn't stay there that long
those teams kind of figure it out they
go back to your old line oh
i don't want to deal with the
distraction i don't want that in the
locker room whatever
hey let's try to find somebody else i
mean again i'm just trying to be honest
and opening up my
my feelings and thoughts here not that
it's right if that kind of stuff's going
on if that kind of stuff's going on yeah
it's our obligation me and you and
everyone who covers the sport
to try to help force the nfl into the
21st century
and and and to get past the neanderthal
thinking whether you know i whether it
was the bullying stuff with richie
incognito and jonathan martin
eight years ago and the things we
learned about stuff that richie
incognito
allegedly slash actually did at a golf
tournament to a female who was working
the course
i mean that kind of behavior that old
school 70s movie
you know how the the the the football
players acted when they got all drunk
and crazy that that stuff
just has to end done across the board
and it's not hard you can still live
your life i mean that's what this is all
ultimately about live your life in a way
that allows other people to live their
lives too
respect who they are they'll respect who
you are
and you can still live your life and you
can still find a way to have fun and you
can still find a way to do crazy things
that don't infringe upon someone else's
rights or feelings it's not that hard to
do
a hundred percent and to add to that
mike like
you know the reality is you know for for
those guys who have those weird awkward
feelings and things like that or
are not accepting of this hey there's
probably
someone gay on your team you know the
reality is there's more than one
in the nfl carl nasim is not the only
guy out there
so you know don't judge you know you
know again yeah be accepting who knows
maybe maybe somebody in your position
room that you like in the locker room
is that it is gay and hasn't is afraid
to come out and those type of things i
mean
i always had the thought that there was
you know one or two guys in every locker
room i was in just to you know
just the numbers game alone and i think
you have to be conscious of that if
you're in any locker room in the nfl to
realize that it is 2021 like you're
saying
and there is a chance that you got one
two maybe three gay guys in the locker
room with you
and you should be aware of that to a
degree
well and it sh and well they should be
aware of the reality
of someone there right right not for who
it is yes but except
that that was another very valuable
message that came from that office
episode that i mentioned because
michael scott didn't know how like he
was when he found out that oscar was gay
it threw him for a loop because like
maybe i know other gay people he had
never even considered it
and so you know in the locker room yeah
but you know the things you do the
things you say
you know you may be offending people who
are deciding to keep who they are to
themselves exactly that's the other side
of it too
i i i remember after michael sam and
kind of while it was going on there was
this pressure
this sense that you know that people
wanted nfl players who were gay
to come out of the closet and say so
that because that that helped
push society forward but ultimately
that's part of the choice you make
as as to how you handle it you are who
you are
you choose to handle it the way that's
right for you and if you choose
that however you are whatever you
are if you choose to keep that private
that's your business
yeah so i i remember the media wrestling
with that
there's a certain element of it that is
you are who you are
and that should be fine and then there
is how you choose to handle it and
that's a strategic decision that
everyone has to make and uh
so you know i i i remember that
awkward time for sure sure where there
were people kind of pushing well someone
else needs to do it now somebody who's
already on a team
who's on a 53-man roster who isn't going
to be cut
who who is so good that no one will ever
say well we don't need the distraction
because you know how it goes for the
star players distract away
yeah bring a rhinoceros to work every
day i don't care
you could play you know awesome whatever
you want to do yeah yeah
so um ultimately people just need to
be who they are and we need to respect
it and we also need to respect whatever
choices they make
as to whether they're going to share who
they are with the rest of the world and
it's that simple it really is that
simple you know we every once in a while
the issue of politics comes up on the
show and i get accused being all sorts
of things
fundamentally i'm libertarian i don't
care
leave me alone and i'll leave you alone
i respect you you respect me let me live
my life you live your life if we can all
get to that point so many of the things
that divide us would no longer divide us
because so much of
our time is spent judging others
and demeaning others and making them
feel like they are different and
therefore
lesser than the rest of us and we just
had john gruden's quote up there yeah
and look i
i don't i'm just going to go ahead and
say there's something about it that
bothers me
his quote is what makes a man different
is what makes him great why are you
applying the label of different
to carl nassen that's part of the
problem
you're different well no you're not
different you just are who you are
we all are who we are we are the same
this is
uh your sexuality is a minor detail of
your life
you ultimately are a human being who
deserves the same respect as everyone
else so it just makes me a little
uncomfortable
to see the label different applied right
out of the gates
to carl nasa maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm
being overly sensitive
but i don't like seeing the word
different as we're trying to to
get people to understand yeah no one's
different we all
are who we are and we need to accept who
we are
no one's different we're unique yeah in
our own way
yeah but but but when you call one guy
in the locker room different
that automatically sets him apart from
the others and i just don't
i don't say well i don't think himself
coming out yeah i don't think gruden
would do that
intentionally just to say that i'll
stick up for him but that's the point
but you're right
i don't think he did it intentionally
either but that's the problem what's the
unconscious stuff that happens
that is so baked in to the experience i
don't even realize it the michael scott
reaction that's my point
well yes but i i again i just use my
experience with gruden i think he's just
like talking about hey
this guy's different from this guy this
guy likes wearing sneakers this guy
wears
loafers this guy wears you know big
boots to work and this guy wears gold
chains to work
you know i i mean i think that's what
he's talking about and different
and what makes him great but you're
right it could have been better language
i will say that i would have preferred a
different quote i know but
i would be shocked if gruden you know
again is not accepting of this he's got
young you know what i mean i know i know
you're not saying that i'm just trying
to throw that out there
you know i yeah he's in the times he's i
just think the kids and those type of
things so he's he's not clueless to the
world
different is an unfortunate word to use
at a time
when we should be striving for
unequivocal
unconditional acceptance of everyone as
who they are and we are all unique in
our own way
and i just think that the sooner we all
respect that
accept that in whatever workplace we're
in
locker room cockpit wherever you may be
whenever you're in close quarters with
someone else they are who they are
you are who you are you show mutual
respect you take care of business
and you go home and you live your life
the way that
you are whether it's choices or just the
way
you are there are a variety of factors
that make up
who we are and we just need to respect
who each other is
and then they will respect hopefully who
we are as well
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports